chance to go up 3-0 toronto does have a
foul to give walker the double team gets
by
walker dishes ties with the dunk with
point five left well they went out to
blitz to trap kimball walker
but he was able to get around and keep
his dribble alive
and then sort of looked him off and made
the bounce pass to tice
lowry stepped up to help ciacom got
looked off he was running out to the
three
you watch ciao come here that's his sink
he should be down on tice
he was worried about the pass coming out
to the three
and then they are able to make the pass
for the dunk
so he gets around here the trap a little
bit gets around gasol into the paint
good help by lowry
siakam has to sink wow right there
how about that a no-look pass to give
boston the lead van vleet with an
acrobatic left-handed layup with some
spin to tie the game and now
boston leads by 2.5
remaining and
one last desperation opportunity here
for toronto special play by kemba walker
and taco fall is going to make an
appearance here
good call taco fall is either going to
be
on the ball which i assume he will be to
make the pass
very very difficult at seven feet five
inches
and he will be he is going to guard the
ball
toronto able to advance it here kyle
lowry's going to have to
inbound against taco fall
wow kyle lowry at not even six feet
boston is going to zone up here on the
side out of bounds they're going to be
switching everything back here
marcus smart's going to stay up high
taking anybody
coming to the ball series on the line
adenomi got it off and it goes
did it count is the question
oh gianna nobody buries a triple
at the buzzer just an absolutely
great pass by kyle lowry let's see if he
kyle lowry over the top gasal just
screened in enough
that ball's gone i think that's a game
and a great winner great shot by ogn
inoby
but an incredible pass by kyle lowry
over taco fall for the game winner
boston
zoned up at the end great play and a
huge win for the toronto raptors all the
talk
about the lack of three-point shooting
for the raptors
in this series and it is a three-ball
from ogie aninobi that
walks off the celtics here tonight
potentially saving toronto season their
first win of this series
and the first time they have beaten
boston here
in the bubble count it big
shot what a moment for o.g annenobi